you know for a guy who campaigned on
spending all of his time in the White
House and for a guy who constantly
attacked President Obama for taking a
few days vacationing Donald Trump this
is going to shock you
Donald Trump is a hypocrite multiple
outlets are reporting on this new
information including the Washington
Post the CNN New York Times but
particularly Newsweek they are reporting
that Trump has spent 25 percent of his
presidency at a trump golf course now I
have to repeat that for dramatic effect
because it is absurd Donald Trump has
spent 25% of his presidency at a trump
golf course
that's right so 150 days of Donald
Trump's 582 days thus far in office have
been spent at his own golf course now
obviously two facets of this number one
the laziness of Donald Trump right but
then also how he is taking America to
the bank Mara Lago you would recall that
as soon as he became president it
doubled this membership fees from
$100,000 for a member to $200,000 for a
member and now Donald Trump is spending
an obscene amount of time across his
properties but we'll get to the amount
of money that he's spending in a minute
I want to read this from Newsweek this
is what they had to say about a quote
Trump often ridiculed former President
Barack Obama for the number of days he
spent on the golf course at the same
point in his presidency Obama had golfed
44 times at this pace the president
Donald Trump will spend roughly 322 days
on the golf course in a four-year term
vastly exceeding the 306 days President
Obama spent golfing during eight years
in the Oval Office and yet Donald Trump
gets it past for this Donald Trump gets
a pass for everything Donald Trump I
mean when you literally this is the
strength I have a lot more to talk about
this particular story but I have to drop
this here this is the strength of your
supporters not caring right this is this
is a horrible thing but if you think
about it in terms of what we do on the
left it's a bad thing on the right they
don't care what Donald Trump does it
doesn't matter he will always be able to
get away with these things
he will never be held accountable by his
own versus on the Left we hold our own
accountable I mean you take a look at
took like take a look at the people who
have al franken who was who had to
resign because of the me2 movement that
wasn't pushed by Republicans his
resignation was pushed by Democrats
because we're holding our own
accountable this is a moral thing too
the moral thing to do it is the right
thing to do but when you are willing to
hold your side accountable and the other
side doesn't care if the president
shoots someone on Fifth Avenue then we
have an asymmetrical fight where they
have the political advantage because no
matter what that person does they would
never be held accountable and while on
our side we're holding ourselves
accountable in addition to the
disingenuous 'no sand the hypocrisy of
the right trying to hold us accountable
i just had to drop that in there because
of how obscene this state of American
politics really is so here's some tweets
from Donald Trump that should remind you
of just how hypocritical he is as if you
needed reminding this is what he said
back when don't uh when Obama was in
office he said can you believe that with
all of the problems and difficulties
facing the u.s. President Obama spent
the day playing golf
worse than Carter I mean really really
horrible for the president to take a day
and play golf Donald Trump was ready to
crucify him or if I were a little edgy I
would say Lynch him but I digress
here's another tweet from Donald Trump
he said Obama has admitted that he
spends his mornings watching ESPN then
he plays golf fundraisers and grants
amnesty to illegals I mean this is
patently not true however but this is
how they operate so it's known as no
there's no utility whatsoever to point
that they're lying because they know
they're lying and that's a part of their
calculus but this is what I mean this is
what we're up against
the president who ran on this the
president who attacked Barack Obama
about this all the time is doing way
worse
I mean multiples times more time spent
on the golf course then President Obama
and nobody has anything to say and this
is what he said recently he said I have
arrived on Twitter he said quote I have
arrived in Scotland and will be a trump
Turnberry for two days of meetings calls
and hopefully get some golf my primary
primary form of exercise the weather's
beautiful and the place is incredible
tomorrow I go to Helsinki for a Monday
meeting with Vladimir Putin so he
clearly has made it known that he has no
shame whatsoever about what he is doing
with America's time and money and just
to put this in context of how much
Donald Trump is spending all of the
complaints that Donald Trump and these
are reports that people have made
previously I mean over the last couple
of months all the complaints that Donald
Trump has had about the cost of the
Muller probe the fact of the matter is
is that Donald Trump has spent more
traveling to his golf courses then Bob
Mahler has spent on the entire probe
thus far this according to the
Washington Post quote the conservative
group Judicial Watch which calculated
similar figures for Obama's presidency
told The Associated Press that it
figured each trip to Mara Lago cost
about 1 million dollars including
including only Air Force one travel and
Secret Service protection this is
including only two subsets of the cost
incurred by the federal government it
doesn't include Judicial Watch told the
AP things like air lifting equipment
such as presidential limousines nor does
it include all the cost of protection in
July of last year the Washington Post
determined that the Coast Guard spent
about 6.6 million on guarding the
beachfront adjacent property over the
course of Trump's first five visits
there if the other visits were similarly
expensive the overall price tag
essentially double
so this is what the president is doing
with his time and this is what the
president is doing with his money and no
one cares no one in power cares not a
single Republican who's concerned about
the the the deficit not a single
conservative who would turn around and
any other administration talked about
fiscal responsibility none of that
matters you know why because they are
playing a game and the game that they
are playing is to hold us accountable on
the left for every single detail while
they absolve the president the sitting
practices President of the United States
of any responsibility to fiscal
responsibility any responsibility to
ethics any responsibility whatsoever